said literally he just stands there
while you act just watched you and
forgets yeah my lines even oh my god
this girl's so good yeah if I didn't
like her I'd be like oh [ __ ] this man I
could spend all this time with this
[ __ ] lady right
but she's so cool I'm telling you right
now like I were we see I had a scene in
a car and we you know and when we were
on the lawn chairs waiting for them set
it up and we it was so just comfortable
and [ __ ] when I did the book shields I
wanted to kill her you know I'm sorry no
offense Brooke but you know a price is
better than you
yeah she yeah she's way better than you
you know I've done stuff with people and
I looked at them innit
like Kim Cattrall when I did that Pepsi
commercial she looks up she goes to Eric
Stonestreet Gus you have a very bright
future and she looks at me and she could
and she just walks away never understand
how people when they get into a certain
position in Hollywood lose like their
decency like it's just as if they don't
actually have the same rules as
everybody else you know be cool don't be
like I don't get it I don't get it when
you get more don't you think you should
like yeah but I'm not nice to extras I
really am NOT because sometimes they'll
like you know sometimes like in between
takes one of them will start singing but
I know what but I know what they're
doing they're showcasing they want to
[ __ ] they're pinning their people on
somebody yeah they want somebody to
notice them yeah and go oh you sing you
want a line yeah we should we're gonna
call and get you an agent you can see
them ham it up and I just want to turn
them ago no no no you're you're like a
tree or up you know or like a building
it should the [ __ ] up it's a weird
business so like of course they're like
you know the need that we feel to be you
know people like us and so they they
want it even worse you know
you got to Bobby I'm sure you showcased
you in your own way I don't ru is
showcasing disappearing it's showcasing
not locking eyes with people and just
kind of turning my back and trembling
that's not showcasing that's me a
[ __ ] artist man I didn't know Joey
you know know one of my point is is that
I wouldn't even do I mean I feel so
guilty even saying what I'm saying but
I'm gonna say it anyway I don't think
that I would never do extra work because
to me I'm like I've done it when I first
started like eight years ago to learn
how to be on a set but you learn by
doing this but did you learn did you
learn yeah I didn't understand with
background rolling what first day ad did
or like house just extras that are what
you described as showcasing and I did
the opposite of that I do it one time
this is something can I just say
something you Josh Duhamel so can I just
say this is you learn by getting a job
too true right yeah and then also it
validates that oh you know I'm a real
actor I'd rather I'd rather additional
additional additional audition get a
couple of lines and learn that way then
being background and I don't think that
helps with the self-esteem I don't think
that helps with but also I don't know
cuz I know is your hand if you think you
think I'm on the line but I know likes a
YouTube star right never been on set I
Cindy has worked with some I don't say
their name but they'll go on set and
they have no idea how to be on set these
are YouTube stars that are like yelling
at the director ton to producer wait for
me and like they've never been on set
those are douchebags true yeah it's
probably really valuable to be on a set
and watch but there's probably a lot of
people who are just sort of looky-loos
to you know yeah around like maybe
you're right maybe I should change my
outlook hey you're not a tree you're not
actually you're giving sorry you can do
extra work if you want we're gonna take
a second for our sponsors
[Music]